plus que deux mois à temps des gueules à
lorient il y aura des vrais meuf passe
puis jeanne meyer la saga
un prof de sport elle mesure grave on a
pu tout un monde sain s'animait
carretera m'a juste des ballons blancs
mais ta gueule on trouve direct après
les croquer et se tient très bien les
méchants tulle bien et pas de bêtises a
dit à ses amis à cities fabia tube qui
peut déconner être oussama bilal beach
volley belle fête à prague rien ça vous
intéresse pas la musique allait briller
au tableau avec manque
11h15 tu fais tu ferais quoi je parle
brothers comment tu parles à bronzer à
face mondiale se passera pas bouffon
quétier mon corps quand le monde qu'on
est les darons direct va y aller à
certaines de merde ont valu milliers sur
son propre terrain taille s il manque un
truc un calibre au non paiement des
rançons
bien sûr les idées qu'on voyait qu'on a
touché 2,6 pdci à la sala to back non
tentée d'injecter à dakar du le guen
c'est super grave pour retrouver
maintenant elle est très longue il faut
qu'on sait pas au rendez-vous et u9 et
j'ai arrêté mais ça je sais pas malo un
peu fugué et au deuil qui voudront
quelque part les jeunes max f
vas-y toi tu crois que tu as un concert
tu fais peur à personne mais franchement
ils ont raison les autres tu es un
looser respect niveaux qui sont vos
enfants que dès qu'ils rentrent je vais
les gronder les veufs et capte rien tu
sais quoi par exemple doit progresser de
m
à
18 ans arrache doublette de merde par sa
mauvaise cosmique havrais